[Music]
have you always wondered how certain
magic tricks work well wonder no more
as we reveal 10 simple magic tricks if
you're new to our channel hit the red
button down below to subscribe
push a coin through a table sleight of
hand is the key to many magic tricks
like this one drop a coin on a table
drag the coin toward the edge of the
table as if you're going to pick it up
but actually sweep it off into your
other hand underneath the table pinch
your fingers and thumb together as if
you really have picked up the coin and
then slam those fingers down flat on the
table at the same time
tap the underside of the table with the
coin bring your hidden hand up to show
you've caught the coin levitating
levitating is one of the most impressive
magic tricks out there but all you need
to be able to do is get your angles
right this is how you perform the
Balducci levitation get your audience to
stand back and then turn yourself 45
degrees to them so they can see the
length of your left foot but only the
heel of your right foot push up on the
toes of your right foot keep your left
foot flat the audience won't be able to
see that your right toes are still on
the ground
a floating match magicians invisible
thread is a wonderful thing tape one end
of it to the corner of a playing card
wrap the thread around the card
lengthwise several times tape the other
end of the card turn the card over and
lay it flat on your hand lay the match
on top at right angles to the thread
squeeze the ends of the card to make it
bend down and wave your free hand over
the top as if you're making the match
levitate in reality it's balancing on
the bed of invisible thread mind reading
the mind-reading card trick works by
distracting your audience start by
secretly looking at the top card of the
deck ask someone to cut the deck and
place it on the table you then mark the
cut which means you place your half of
the pack at right-angles on top of their
half talk to them for a while this is
called time misdirection you then pick
up your half of the deck and get them to
look at the top card of theirs they will
have forgotten that this is in fact the
bottom card of their deck they cut to
they'll be looking at the top card of
the whole deck of cards
moving ring if you can control a piece
of elastic bag you can do the moving
ring trick start off with an elastic
band that you've cut so that it's a flat
length with two ends ask someone in the
audience for their ring preferably a
thin round wedding band as this works
best place the ring on the elastic Bend
make sure you keep an extra bit of the
elastic hidden behind your thumb and
forefinger then simply pull the elastic
tight and let the hit an extra length
slip slowly through your fingers the
ring will stay stuck on the same spot
but it will look like it's moving uphill
link paper clips tell your audience you
have circus performing paper clips ask
for a film fold it three quarters of the
way along and fold it back again so it
overlaps with each end sticking out
about half an inch one centimeter place
one paper clip on one end so that it
joins the front side in the middle
overlap place the other clip on the
other end joining the backside of the
bill and the middle overlap pull the
ends of the bill apart to straighten it
and the clips will join together and
flip up in the air turn water into ice
instantly certain magic tricks take
preparation but it's worth it place a
few bottles of purified water on their
side in the freezer at around minus 24
degrees Celsius - 11 Fahrenheit check
after an hour and a half to see if
they're still liquid
keep checking every 15 minutes when the
first bottle has started to freeze
slowly remove the rest the water hasn't
frozen yet because there are no
impurities to start the process
something as simple as a jolt to the
side of the bottle will make the
crystals form or pour your water over
ice and watch it make an impressive
frozen Tower find their card one of the
most classic card tricks is when the
magician finds the card there audience
member picked out and all it takes is
one secret move once they've chosen
their card you turn away so you can't
see them show the card to their friends
whilst they're not looking flip the deck
over and then turn the top two cards
back so it looks like the entire deck is
facedown as before they place their card
back in you hold on to it to cover up
the second card and then spread the
whole deck their card will be the only
one facedown stand a glass of water on a
playing card
show off your amazing balancing skills
by placing a glass of water on top of a
playing card or so it seems what you're
really doing is using a trick card make
sure your audience is head-on so they
can't see behind your card when you
place your card on its end on the table
secretly push out the hitting card stuck
to the back it looks like the card is
standing upright and the glass is
balancing on the cards edge but you've
created a stand for the card and glass
to rest on cut an assistant in half
sawing an assistant in half is one of
the most iconic magic tricks ever and
we're about to ruin the illusion by
revealing how it's done but that's why
you're watching this video right there
are actually two assistants one in each
box the chamber is deeper than the table
looks so the head and hides its body
underneath and the feet and hides its
head and body underneath which magic
trick is most impressive let us know in
the comments and give us a big thumbs up
[Music]